bill cosby is officially a free man
on wednesday the pennsylvania supreme
court overturned the 83-year-old actor's
2018 conviction
for drugging and sexually assaulting
andrea constand in 2004 according to
court documents obtained by e.t
according to the docs the court found
that an agreement that cosby had with a
previous prosecutor
prevented him from being charged in the
case cosby had already served more than
two
years of his prison sentence which was
set to last between three and ten years
he was denied parole in may and it's
still unclear whether prosecutors will
appeal the court's decision
last june cosby's wife camille showed
her support for her husband's appeal
telling abc news at the time that she
was hopeful about the possibility of
quote
vindication that is the goal she added
there are possibilities now finally
there is a court that has said wait a
minute there are some problems here they
can be considered for appeal
stick with et for updates as the story
continues